[Music]  [Music]  tensions are mounting on the  israeli-egyptian border if thousands of  soldiers are massing the fear remains  that war could break out at any time  [Music]  in three days  Egypt will attack Israel  [Music]  this Israeli embassy how may I direct  your call  Israeli ambassador please I have  information of interested Israeli  intelligence services I want to watch  every move you make find out whose side  he's on the son of the great Nasser  working for Israelis if it is something  people have to do something bigger  [Applause]  why are you helping Israel because  millions of innocent people will die on  both sides that's life you can't leave  me I'm trying to save our family no one  you're known as the angel I like it  you need to learn to handle no acid you  want to save Israel  you want to save the lives of your  soldiers  you  [Music]